[Music]  Justin Bieber's bod is covered in 56  tattoos and his latest Instagram post  has fans wondering if he got a fifty  seven beads posted this pic of a site at  which reads better at 70 say sorry he  captioned the post quote I look back at  a lot of things in my life mistakes  insecurities and although I have felt  I've wasted a lot of time it also makes  me want to be better faster and longer  for me personally I want to work every  day to be better at 70 the face of the  person the ink belongs to is never  revealed but in another post beaver  sings the phrase while his friend and  pastor Judah Smith gets the same words  inked on his leg it's unclear if Justin  got the tattoo too or just likes its  meaning but either way the 23 year old  has 47 years to go to be  [Music]